joe biden came in and on day one
he stripped back a border policy that
was the most effective border policy
i've ever seen in my 27 plus years of
arizona i covered arizona for 27 years i
covered the border for men all those
years and we never saw it better than
when president trump was in charge he
had
secured our border the best i'd ever
seen it and on day one joe biden came
and tore that back completely exposed us
to a criminal element handed over
control of our border to narco
terrorists and they immediately
started to bring in people from all over
the world not just mexico and central
america people from 160 countries are
pouring in coming up through our
southern border and joe biden's pretty
much giving them citizenship by what
he's done
so i want to jump back to the border
stuff in just a sec but can you talk a
little bit about what generally is going
on in arizona i think most people think
of arizona and they're like no no it
should be a red state it seems like it's
a red state but it doesn't fully seem to
be a red state it really as you're
saying could go either way it's a little
hard to understand what the electorate
is is really made up of there or where
they're really going well let me tell
you arizona is as red as my shirt okay
it's a red state
but
when we have corrupt elections that are
stolen
where we have a mail-in ballots being
sent out to people who don't even live
here and filled out and sent in and we
have ballot trafficking and we have
more voters than even registered voters
voting
then we're going to have a corrupt
election that makes it look like we
aren't a red state and that's why it is
imperative
that we get to the bottom of this
election
and we do not allow another election to
be stolen it's not about republican
democrat independent it's about having
honest elections
and saving our country so we're a red
state absolutely we have a lot of people
coming over from california believe it
or not a lot of them are conservatives
who are fleeing they're political
refugees coming in from oregon and and
washington california and other blue
states and of course we do have some
coming in who are bringing their liberal
ideology with them and we're really not
interested in becoming california so um
we are a very conservative state a wild
west state and we've got
issue with our border that does not
remain here in arizona when we have
people flowing across people being
trafficked drugs being trafficked they
move to other states beyond arizona i
was just in north carolina for the trump
rally and the good people of north
carolina i think their number one issue
is the border they were chanting build
the wall finish the wall in north
carolina think how far they are from the
border
this is a
an issue that is an american issue not
just an arizona issue and we've got to
get a strong governor in who is going to
finish the wall send troops to the
border and secure our border for the
rest of the country as well
how did this happen with the border do
you think i mean we've been covering
this a lot and reading off the numbers
and it's gotten significantly worse
under biden obviously but what happened
in arizona and texas that allowed so
much of this that allowed so many people
to come in and not just come in but they
come in illegally and then they're
shipped to other states i don't know if
you've seen but my governor here
in florida desantis any any illegals
that they ship here he's shipping them
to delaware i highly recommend i highly
recommend you institute a policy like
that uh once you're governor but what do
you think happened in arizona that led
to this well i have a better idea we're
not letting them in in the first place
we're gonna keep them from coming in and
we're gonna find them when they're here
we're gonna send them back across the
border that way our tax money's not
going to pay for them um what happened
was joe biden and what happened before
that was a corrupt election that got joe
biden into office
and joe biden came in and on day one
he stripped back a border policy that
was the most effective border policy
i've ever seen in my 27 plus years of
arizona i covered arizona for 27 years i
covered the border for men all of those
years and we never saw it better than
when president trump was in charge he
had secured our border the best i'd ever
seen it and on day one joe biden came
and tore that back completely exposed us
to a criminal element handed over
control of our border to narco
terrorists and they immediately
started to bring in people from all over
the world not just mexico and central
america people from 160 countries are
pouring in coming up through our
southern border and joe biden's pretty
much giving them citizenship by what
he's done and it's going to stop when
i'm governor we are going to shut it
down we're gonna finish the wall and
we're you know have you seen the video
of of all of that material that we've
already paid for i was just down there
and
it's outrageous i was down there in
southern arizona walking next to it it
goes on for a mile it's stacked up
probably 20 feet high and it's just
materials for building the wall sitting
there in the desert we're going to take
that back under my border plan we're
going to redefine what it means to have
abandoned federal property and we're
going to use that to finish the wall we
paid for it
we paid for that material and we're also
going to send our arizona national
guard down to the border we're going to
arm them because we're not going to put
them up against these cartel members
without arming them and we're going to
have them
push people back and not allow people to
come across our border if we catch them
we arrest them for trespassing detain
them process them and send them back
across the border and we do have the
right to do that we're going to ask
other states who are interested
like-minded states to chip in and help
maybe they send their state guard down
and we will use them and utilize them at
the border to make sure we have enough
manpower on the border our constitution
allows for this dave the constitution
article 4 section 4 the guarantee clause
it requires the federal government
protect us from invasion and when they
fail to do that in article 1 section 10
clause 3
the states have the power
to take control it's almost state war
power to take control of their troops
and stop the invasion which we intend to
do beginning on day one of my
administration
do you sense that that's kind of the
future of america and not just talking
about borders but in general that will
return to some level of federalism that
we were intended to where the state
that you live in in some ways will be
more important than the federal
government i mean that's really the way
the whole thing was set up it doesn't
seem to be the way we we think we're
supposed to be governed but i sense that
coming back i can tell you from living
in california for the last eight years
to where i live in florida right now it
is it is like living in a completely
different country and i'm actually okay
with that
we're going to learn the weak states
versus the strong states you could call
the blue states versus the red states
and i agree with you i mean we realized
during covet just how strong the states
were
we've handed over way too much power by
the way to the federal government so
it's about time we bring that power back
to the states but we learned when our
governors
exerted their power against the people
during covet how much power they had
unfortunately they used that power
to torture us to shut our businesses
down to shut our churches down to send
our schools um closing and sending our
kids home
they forced our kids to mask up they
forced people to get shots against their
will so they use that power in the most
devious way in my opinion
i plan to use that power to strengthen
arizona protect arizona and give the
power back to the people
and and you can see it
as as broad as daylight when you go to a
florida when you go to a red state when
you go to a state like california where
these
terrible uh radical leftist policies
have been in play for 40 plus years in
california they've completely destroyed
what used to be a once great state and
so i believe going back to state power
is the way to go to go back to our
sovereignty we created the federal
government
they didn't create us and we are
sovereign not serfs of the federal
government
what do your opponents say what like
when you're talking to the democrats or
if they're just talking about you maybe
they're not talking to you i mean what
are they saying on the border that i
mean is any are they saying anything
that resonates with people or that makes
sense like what is what is the policy of
a border state democrat at this point
well i'm actually impressed with um that
we're leading the charge my campaign is
i've been on day one talking about the
border calling it an invasion calling it
what it is and now my republican
opponents are now jumping and even
stealing parts of my plan which is fine
because my plan is the best plan out
there for securing the border so i'm
actually pushing the the just the entire
discussion on what we need to do across
the country even i've had other people
reach out to me and say can i take a
look at your plan we might want to
implement it here i have sent it over to
our current governor doug ducey and said
please implement this immediately we
can't wait until i'm voted into office
we can't wait until january 23 we need
to start this right away
he never responded to that i hope if
he's listening that he will take a look
at it and implement it immediately it's
the only way we can protect the good
people of arizona and of america if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell